there's a new religion in north american
league of legends they don't have mass
on sundays they don't visit the mosque
or synagogue and to join them you just
have to believe in the divine powers of
one man known simply as ls since his
appointment as cloud 9's head coach last
year he's pulled out some of the most
crazy picks and drafts the lcs has seen
in years
but they actually work welcome to the
church of ls let me show you around
[Music]
look i knew i was going to talk about ls
this year i just didn't think it would
be this quick we'll definitely be
discussing him more later on in the year
though so if you don't want to miss that
make sure you subscribe to the score
esports and turn notifications on just
do it it makes sense it makes so much
sense all right first off ls aka last
shadow has a pretty wild backstory he
first appeared in esports as a starcraft
player during this time he battled
homelessness depression the struggles of
coming out and living alone in korea as
well as a cheating scandal that almost
cut his career short over a decade ago
we covered this era of his life in one
of our shorts videos so check that out
if you want to know more about his
career before league but since 2014 ls
has become one of the most famous
analytical minds in league of legends
particularly in korea where he's coached
the likes of bbq oliver's and was a
content creator for t1 and for the past
two years or so he took a step back from
coaching to focus on co-streaming pro
games from around the world as they
aimlessly push a 500 gold tier one
turret and t1 electa clap back what the
hell are they doing never mind not t1
make it throw one
what the fudge is do you see this you
see what's going on right now
now from the outside ls seemed very
comfortable in korea and certainly
didn't see the need to return to western
league and their uh
[ __ ]
i don't until if you play with me you
like cut the western [ __ ]
which is why it came as a bit of a
surprise on december 1st last year the
ls will be returning to m.a to become
the head coach of cloud9 along came the
offer from cloud9 and i thought if there
was ever going to possibly be a chance
to return to pro play and some facet
coaching this probably would have just
been it look ls returning to coaching
and north america was huge news whether
or not you're a cloud 9 fan he clearly
has one of the most analytical mind in
the game and in any given stream you'd
often find him theorycrafting why an
overlooked item is broken why a certain
strategy is secretly op or why a
particular champion is loki busted i'm
gonna show you
all why we pick annie ready
he's a famous champion of color theory
in drafting the belief that champions
belong to certain color groups based on
their strengths and that certain colors
work well together it's heavily based on
the deck building theory of magic the
gathering and its application to league
of legends by ls gives a real insight
into his strategical mind okay so
there's one color here
now the enemy team responds gangplank
gangplank is green white and blue for
the most part
now white creatures or white things are
not now even though blue is often weak
early on and green is often weak early
on it doesn't mean that
the champion just because it has those
two colors has to be that way to put it
simply he's built different the question
was though would he bring his outside
the box thinking to the lcs or would he
play it safe in his first real coaching
position for almost three years well we
got our answer pretty quick oh my god
i'm curious that's a lot
here wait this could be remember this
could be ivern jungle or it could be
ivor top playing like a janna as well
how we're going to get soraka oh oh my
god this is the quintessential ls
champion he's put this thing in s tier
and solo lanes every patch you know like
this is the champ fudge playing ivan and
then soraka mid were some of the
strangest picks we've seen in the lcs in
quite a while but they both helped c9 to
an impressive 2-0 start to the season
i'm putting a quick hold on the ls story
for just a second i want to take a
moment to acknowledge just how much has
changed for fudge over the past six
months he's gone from being a top laner
on bruises and duelists to being a mid
laner on support champions like soraka
and ivan budge is coming in berserker's
gonna be taking low but he will get away
look at the shielding on the man god
bless that is a lot of extra hp now
obviously he's gonna play a lot of
normal mids too but yeah fudge playing
soraka in the mid lane is not one i had
down for 2022. listen it's cool that ls
is bringing out some crazy pics this
early on but that's not all he's brought
to the lcs so far c9 fans have also been
very impressed with summit and berserker
the two young koreans who have been
brought in as the team's top and bot
laners respectively these guys have
looked really solid in their first few
weeks in an entirely different country
and league a lot less shaky than tsm's
eastern imports and while this may be
down to the players themselves or cloud9
as an org you can't overlook ls's hand
in all of this too ls actually worked
directly with cloud9's owner and staff
during the off season while they were
piecing this team together what i can
say is that even while these decisions
were going on i had agreed to help
cloud9 regardless of if i would end up
joining or not i thought that the
players that have been picked up summit
berserker are two of the best players
that could have been picked up for
imports now we don't know if ls
hand-picked the likes of summit or
berserker but this c9 roster which looks
very different to last year's definitely
has ls's prince all over it ellis also
said in his announcement video that he
was the one that had a conversation with
fudge about swapping to the mid lane the
fudge swap to mid lane was a
conversation that i did have with fudge
and i've spoken very highly of fudge as
a player fundamentally and i just
thought it doesn't matter if you're top
or mid lane you're still going to be one
of the best western players if not the
best western player
in a very short period of time now look
swapping roles isn't anything unheard of
in league but it's a whole new thing for
a brand new coach to just stroll in and
get one of their players to completely
change their lane and that wouldn't
happen unless they trusted their coach
c9 and their players clearly do now
obviously fudge does have somewhat of a
prior relationship with ls they used to
do a lot of co-streams together but
their relationship gives a clue about
something that a lot of western fans
might have overlooked ls's man
management skills we're all used to his
big brain analytical takes he's known
for number crunching and optimizing his
unpredictable drafting style makes it
even more difficult for opponents who
face him and he'll flex any champion you
can think of he flex your mom
in a recent cloud9 behind the scenes
video you can literally see ls showing
fudge how to play ivan mid before he
took it on stage a pic that he said he
accidentally discovered when he locked
in ivan mid in solo queue by mistake
that is some faith right there and then
in the following game you can see the
team go from disbelief that he wants
them to play soraka in the mid lane to
acceptance when they realize the mad lad
might actually be onto something
she just beats everyone by them
actually beats everyone
how many coaches walk into a team that
they're already familiar with that
they're already fond of they've got a
big head start on a lot of other teams
look i'm not trying to write a fairy
tale before it's even happened here at
the time of recording we haven't even
seen week three of the lcs yet there's a
lot that could happen between now and
the end of the season and despite all
the hype their loss to team liquid in
week two clearly shows that they're not
completely invincible but that's kind of
not the point here the excitement around
ls and c9 isn't entirely to do with
whether they win or lose it's about a
team of unknown quantities the opposite
of a somewhat tried and tested roster
like team liquids being led into battle
every week by a mad genius who puts them
on champions in roles that he discovered
by mistake you have to respect he's
coming to the lcs with these weird and
wacky comps that he's been talking about
he talks the talk he walks the walk he
says he what he thinks is strong he
plays it and it actually works and you
got to be like hats off to him even if
you disagree with the other like
you don't like his streams something
like come on guys you got to give him
some respect because he's coming in
shifting the meta he's making these
teams actually think oh maybe this is
strong maybe we need to view the game in
a different light and that's what i'm
all about league of legends progression
i don't want people just going and
copying other teams and being like this
is why they don't grow they gotta do
this because they don't create strong
think for yourselves innovate that's why
there's a holy aura surrounding cloud9
right now that's why people are flocking
to the church of ls and yes if cloud9
fans are very lucky and they say their
prayers at night they might just see a
miracle this year
it's a bit of an advanced insult like
talking a lot for someone whose room
looks like mordekaiser's old
just the [ __ ] death realm i mean look
at the background
it's just
sad
it is despair and regret
and just horrible horrible emotions
the second you walk in you just feel if
you walk into your room with a with a
plant it will die right away